AS SOURCES ARE SCRAMBLING FOR
DETAILS ON OTHERS.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS TELLS US WHAT HE IS
HEARING FROM THE NORTH LAWN
NORTH LAWN.
>> THE RUMOR MILL IS WORKING
OVERTIME ON POTENTIAL STAFF
CHANGES AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE OTHER DAY AND LAST WEEK, THE
PRESIDENT SUGGESTED THERE WERE
MORE CHANGES AHEAD.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THESE ARE GOING
TO HAPPEN.
BUT WE ARE TOLD THERE COULD BE A
BLOODBATH.
IF NOT TOMORROW, THEN FRIDAY AT
THE LATEST.
THE CHANGES I AM BEING TOLD TO
WATCH FOR.
H.R. MCMASTER, NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR TO BE REPLACED BY
AMBASSADOR JOHN BOLTON.
ANOTHER POSSIBLE CHANGE, THE
SECRETARY DAVID SHULKIN TO BE
REPLACED BY ENERGY SECRETARY
RICK PERRY.
RICK PERRY HAS BEEN TELLING
PEOPLE HE LIKES IT AT ENERGY AND
IS NOT INCLINED TO MOVE OVER TO
THE VA.
POSSIBLY REPLACING.
ENERGY WOULD BE THE OVERSEAS
PRIVATE INVESTMENT CORPORATION
CHAIRMAN RAY WASHBURN.
ANOTHER POSSIBLE DEPARTURE, THIS
ONE MAY BE FURTHER OFF.
JOHN KELLY TWO POTENTIALLY BE
REPLACED BY MICK MULVANEY.
SOME PEOPLE SAY THE PRESIDENT
MAY BE IN A POSITION WHERE HE
WANTS TO RIP THE BAND-AID OFF
AND GET THIS ALL DONE IN ONE
FELL SWOOP.
OTHER PEOPLE SAYING SOME OF
THESE CABINET CHANGES MAY TAKE A
LITTLE LONGER.
SWAPPING OUT YOUR NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR.
THERE WAS ONE ADDITION TO THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY AFTER DAYS OF
IT BEING REMADE, THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED THE NEW HEAD OF
INTERNATIONAL ECONOMIC COUNCIL.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH HIS CURRENT
LAWYER, LARRY KUDLOW CONFIRMED
HE WILL BE THE PRESIDENT'S NEW
CHIEF ECONOMIC ADVISOR.
>> WE ARE GOING TO GET ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HE IS COMPLETELY IN COMMAND.
AS HE ALWAYS DOES, HE ASKS
QUESTIONS.
IF I TRIED TO GIVE HIM THE
KUDLOW THING, HE IS GOING TO
COME BACK AND HE'S A SMART MAN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KUDLOW
DON'T SEE EYE TO EYE ON EVERY
ISSUE BUT THEY'VE KNOWN EACH
OTHER FOR DECADES.
KUDLOW WAS ONE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S EARLIEST
SUPPORTERS DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
>> I'VE KNOWN HIM A LONG TIME.
WE DON'T AGREE ON EVERYTHING BUT
IN THIS CASE I THINK THAT'S
GOOD.
I WANT TO HAVE DIVERSE OPINIONS.
WE AGREE ON MOST.
HE NOW HAS COME AROUND TO